here's the thing the thing about the
debt-free screams is they come in every
age every background every amount every
race every career type it's Americana
but it's not really Americana because
they're not in debt anymore and the
typical person in America today is in
debt they've got a student loan that's
been around so long we think it's a how
a pet
we've got car payments and car fleeces
they're using their credit card and
$17,000 in credit card debt and
somewhere they remember a discussion
over too many beers about how they were
using those points to their advantage
which is a freaking joke all the money
comes in all the money goes out when
they look at their children there's a
sense of desperation because they look
like college student loans looking for a
place to happen when they think about
retirement they get cold chills because
they know they've got no money
and they know depending on the
government which is well-known for its
ability to handle money to take care of
them is a dumb idea 78% of Americans are
living paycheck to paycheck normal is
broke and making way too much money to
be that dadgum broke that's normal and
then along comes a 28 year old a 24 year
old 35 year old or a 52 year old
standing across the lobby from me with
headsets on doing their debt-free screen
they're not only yelling that they're
free they're yelling at you that you
should not be normal anymore you should
say I'm not gonna do this anymore
oh but Dave I'm a victim you're not a
victim Dave you don't know about the ism
that I face we all face isms some of us
more than others welcome to life but
there are people that are doing debt
free screams in spite of whatever ISM
they faced sexism ageism racism bald ISM
whatever it is you face whatever it is
that people mistreat you because of that
fat shaming whatever it is that whatever
excuse you have for your little
snowflake self to have your feelings
hurt people do it in spite of that they
do it in spite of that and you can too
is it easy well board
no it's not easy winning is not easy
they don't interview guys after the
Super Bowl and they go well that was
really easy they don't say that
winning is not easy I have never met
someone who has had wealth and kept it
for years they've been a millionaire for
a decade or more
they weren't get rich quick in other
words they were in a lotto winner
there's someone that made money and kept
it I've never met one of them they said
it was easy
and yet I hear easy payments advertised
in 10 easy payments you ever had a
payment that was easy I've never had an
easy payment facing somebody think
they're out there though so when are you
gonna decide that you're gonna be weird
normals broke darling the biggest
compliment you can get once you call in
on this show is for me to call you weird
because it means you're not broke
anymore and you're not living like broke
people and you're not thinking like
broke people